[Music]
but we begin tonight with US Surgeon
General dr. Jerome Adams dr. Adams thank
you so much for being with us tonight
I know the long days and a lot of work
ahead of you hello there so first of all
I want to ask you about some breaking
news just moments ago with regard to
someone testing positive in vice
president Pence's office can you tell us
anything about that well one thing I can
tell you is that White House medical
staff was fantastic they called me right
away they said this is a person who you
did not have any contact with and you
are at low to no risk and they asked me
if I had any symptoms and I said no and
so they told me I didn't need to be
tested and so I just want to really say
thank you to the White House medical
staff they were very professional and
they will continue to hear about more
cases across the country and it's
important that we all remain calm and
that we remember that if you didn't have
direct exposure if you don't have
symptoms then you don't need to be
tested but you should always talk to
your medical provider so what did you
make of that exchange that we just
played between reporter Peter Alexander
and the president sort of this debate
over whether or not the White House is
putting too rosy a spin on things at
this point what do you say to that well
the messaging has always been
challenging because we're trying to to
get people optimism but also encourage
them to be cautious and it's why from
the beginning I've always said we need
to prepare but not panic and you see
panic in some places and that results in
people hoarding that results in people
pulling knives on each other over
hand-sanitizer
we do need to calm people down and from
my experience that's what the president
has always tried to do is calm people
down while also really helping people
understand this is serious and we all
need to lean into it and you saw that
earlier this week with the 15 days to
stop the spread guidelines that the
president put out saying look America
it's go time
so do you think the president is being
overly optimistic about the
anti-malarial drug and REM disavow which
have seen some positive results in some
trials well I wasn't at today's press
conference were practicing social
distancing but I did see it I was quite
frankly fascinated at these stories that
came out of that
because there was no there was no
disconnect between what Tony felt she
was saying and what the president was
saying the president was saying number
one we have two drugs out there and he
is optimistic and hopeful based on some
of the studies and what they've heard
that these drugs will be helpful to
people and it's why we're providing them
for four people on a compassionate use
basis but Tony Falchi appropriately said
we need to make sure we're following up
the data that we see the studies so that
we can actually tell people for certain
down the road whether this is effective
or not so those two aren't incongruent
that science we're hopeful but we're
also people when they want I'm sorry
what do they tell people you tell people
when they say you know when will these
be sort of in common use when we can and
when anyone who is you know in the
hospital with breathing trouble would be
given these drugs right away what's the
time frame well that's a fantastic
question and we've always told people we
have kind of a three tiered response and
I'll go backwards tier 3 is vaccines we
know it will likely be next year before
we get a vaccine for this disease tier 2
is actually looking at therapeutics
things like rim def severe like like the
drugs that you heard about today and
we've always said it will probably be
mid summer before we have enough data to
be able to say for certain whether or
not these drugs are promising they're
now being made available in record
timing on a compassionate use basis just
in case but Tier one is actually
mitigation and when you look at this
outbreak and all other outbreaks you
don't solve these outbreaks the first
go-round with therapeutics so with
vaccines you solve them by social
distancing we saw that in the 1918 flu
outbreak we're seeing it in Singapore we
saw it in South Korea and in China it's
making sure you stay six feet away from
people it's the president's guidelines
making sure you are in groups of less
than ten making sure you're pulling down
unnecessary travel I think everybody yes
well I hope everybody knows that bunny
because when you look in some places so
it's important to reinforce all those
social medications so it is I totally
agree and I think it's you know I was
just gonna say I think people are really
trying to adapt to it
credit and we've been hard on our
Millennials and our Gen Z's but a lot of
them out there doing great things that I
just want to give a shout out to to the
folks who gave blood after I put out my
announcement at the press conference
yesterday letting people know that
there's a shortage of blood in this
country but it is safe to give blood you
know we got good people in this country
and I'm confident that they will rally
and do the right thing all right let's
put up this chart that shows the
acceleration in the last 14 days which
is dramatic but that was it was expected
right because we're seeing so many more
people being tested now well exactly
we've seen a big increase in testing
this week and that's resulted in more
positives but we also need to be be
straight about it with everyone we are
where Italy was just a few weeks ago in
terms of numbers and we have to make a
decision that we want to go the
trajectory of Italy or do we want to
look more like South Korea like
Singapore and what South Korea and
Singapore did was aggressive social
mitigation the scientists on the task
force shared that information with the
vice president and the president and
they said let's put out these guidelines
right now to give States the tools that
they need and the cover that they need
to make some of these tough decisions
you're seeing governors making so I said
that we had a couple of questions there
were actually a lot of really good
questions that came in on Twitter on
your Twitter with people that you would
be with us tonight
okay so here's one from Stephen has the
federal government identified each of
the hospitals in the United States with
an immediate if not urgent need for
protective gear for their doctors and
nurses have they identified them Surgeon
General and how long will it be before
all those needs are met that is a great
question and I am still a practicing
physician I practice at Walter Reed
these physicians are calling me directly
what I want you to know is that a couple
of big things happen this week you had
the the bill that was passed at the
president sign which which allows 30
more million masks a month from 3m and
Honeywell to be made available for
medical use you also saw the Department
of Defense donate from their stockpile
ventilators and masks and importantly
FEMA went to level 1 and folks don't
understand but what that means is that
FEMA can work directly with the states
the way they work with them through
hurricanes and they
have this down to a science to make sure
they figure out who needs what and to
get it to them because right now one of
the problems is the majority of the
supplies are going out into the open
market and they may not be going to
where they need to be it's why we also
put out guidelines to pull down elective
procedures this week we don't need
people in one part of the country using
PPE to do less of cases and cosmetic
surgery while people in New York or in
Washington are suffering because they
can't actually take care of themselves
to take care of the patients I'm gonna
squeeze in one more if you could give me
if you're able to give me a quick answer
I'd appreciate it this is from Lars
testing positive for coronavirus means
that we need to isolate at home but
since we are already isolating at home
anyway what is gained by getting the
test
well what's gained by getting the test
is that hopefully you will be even more
vigilant because we know that people
aren't always following those social
mitigation guidelines but also if you go
into the hospital if you get sicker it's
important for your healthcare providers
to know so that they can appropriately
use PPE and protect themselves one of
our tenants is we need to protect the
people who are out there protecting the
people and I want the healthcare
providers out there and the first
responders to know we are trying as hard
as we can to make sure we are getting
you PPE where you need it as your
Surgeon General I still practice and
I've got your back we are leaning into
this dr. Adams thank you very much good
to have you with us tonight keep up the
good work I know everybody's really
working overtime and hard on this and we
really appreciate you taking some time
with us tonight Thank You Marcia
coronavirus gov and and again I'm happy
to answer more questions on Twitter
great we'll look forward to it thank you
so much dr. Jerome Adams the Surgeon
General